single-use plastic like straws cotton  buds and cutlery make up 70 percent of  marine litter Parliament voted to ban  the sale of these items from 2021  members voted to make Road charging  distance base for trucks and buses from  2023 the new rules aim to better reflect  actual Road use and pollution generated  ukrainian filmmaker oleg sentsov has won  the 2018 Sakharov Prize for freedom of  thought he is being convicted to 20  years in prison for plotting terrorist  acts against the russian de facto rule  in crimea the parliament condemned the  killing of journalist jamal khashoggi in  the Saudi consulate in Istanbul and  called for an immediate investigation  Saudi Arabia ranks 169 in the world for  press freedom in 2018 every year 25,000  people die in the EU from infections  from superbugs Parliament voted to try  to curb the rise in antimicrobial  resistance by restricting the use of  antibiotics in farming